and there is a no quick solution to all
of this but I want of course the
Security Council to use all the tools
available to them including sanctions
looking at whether we can put
perpetrators to justice and to put them
on their lists I want the government in
the DRC and everywhere where this is a
problem it's not only an African problem
to take this seriously also to do
everything they can to ensure that we
put an end to impunity to address the
problem of impunity and also to assist
the women to empower women to make sure
that they have a voice and a seat at the
table where decision are made so there
are no number of things that the UN has
to ensure that in peacekeeping
operations we can protect the civilians
and that means women that we have to
look at the best ways to to protect
civilians
well we are contacted by a lot of people
who have great ideas about to equip
women with everything from sort of small
small weapons that could help them to
defend themselves to to communication
gadgets you know that they can warn
other women that they can call for help
etc and I I think everything is worth
testing you know we have to do
everything but the thing is it should
not fall on the women to actually also
have to to sort of physically defend
themselves this is also response it's
not a women's issue this is a peace and
security issue and we have to make sure
that we go after the perpetrator so i
would put much more focus on on finding
the perpetrators and punishing them to
close every exit every possible career
possibility for for these guys so that
they know that there is no mercy for for
rapists